♪
>> Katie: GRAB YOUR POPCORN,
JOE BIDEN IS ABOUT TO SET OFF
THE SQUAD, THE UPCOMING PROPOSAL
WILL NOT HAVE A CAMPAIGN PROMISE
WIPING OUT $10,000 PER PERSON IN
STUDENT DEBT.
THEN KENNA DIDN'T SAID HE WOULD
DO IT IMMEDIATELY.
>> I'M GOING TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY IN THIS GENERATION
GETS $10,000 KNOCKED OFF OF
THEIR STUDENT DEBT AS WE TRY TO
GET OUT OF THIS GOD-AWFUL
PANDEMIC.
>> Katie: DOES THIS HAVE
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
INFLATION REPORTS WE HAVE SEEN
SPENDING MONEY?
BEFORE IT GOES BACK TO WHAT HE
TRULY BELIEVES, A WHILE AGO YOU
SAID SOMETHING LIKE THE IDEA
THAT YOU GO TO PEN AND ARE
PAYING A TOTAL OF 72 GRAND A
YEAR AND THEY PAY FOR THAT, I
DON'T AGREE.
SO AT ONE POINT HE SAID THAT,
AND I THINK THAT THAT IS
ACTUALLY HIS TRUE FEELINGS, BUT
I ALSO THINK THAT HE IS STARTING
TO BOW TO REALITY, POLITICAL
GRAVITY IS TAKING HOLD AND THEY
ARE REALIZING THAT THEIR SECOND
HUNDRED DAYS WILL BE MUCH
TOUGHER THAN THEIR FIRST HUNDRED
AND THIS IDEA OF STUDENT LOAN
FORGIVENESS IS A NO-GO WHEN IT
COMES TO CONGRESS.
HOWEVER SENATOR CHUCK SCHUMER
HAS BEEN WEARING A MASK THAT
SAYS CANCEL STUDENT DEBT AS HE
COWERS IN FEAR OF THE PRIMARY
POTENTIALLY, SO I DON'T THINK
THAT THE LEFT WILL GIVE UP
WITHOUT A FIGHT, BUT I DON'T
THINK THAT THIS IS GOING TO
HAPPEN.
>> Katie: GREG, I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THIS, BECAUSE THEY
ACT LIKE THEY ARE FOR THE LITTLE
GUY AND THE LOWER CLASS, BUT THE
STUDENT LOAN FORGIVENESS
OVERWHELMINGLY BENEFITS WEALTHY
PEOPLE.
>> Greg: IT DOES, THERE IS
THIS FALLACY BEHIND ALL OF THIS
THAT SOMEHOW THESE PEOPLE THAT
YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT ARE
CHOOSING BETWEEN PAYING THEIR
STUDENT LOAN AND EATING, OH, MY
GOD, THIS IS SUCH A HARDSHIP.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE AVERAGE
STUDENT LOAN, RIGHT?
IT'S ROUGHLY THE SAME GIVE OR
TAKE AS A CAR LOAN, IT MIGHT
EVEN BE ROUGHLY THE SAME AS YOUR
INTERNET CABLE SMARTPHONE BILL.
SO I DON'T THINK THAT PEOPLE ARE
HAVING --
YOU CANNOT COMPARE IT TO
SOMETHING LIKE RENT, WHY CAN'T,
AND I HAVE SAID THIS BEFORE, A
SHEET METAL WORKER WHO DIDN'T GO
TO COLLEGE CLAIMED THAT HE WANTS
HIS CAR PAYMENT CANCELED BECAUSE
IT IS ROUGHLY THE SAME COSTS AND
HIS TRUCK IS CONTRIBUTE AND MORE
TO SOCIETY THAN AN ART HISTORY
DEGREE BY FAR, SO WHY ARE THOSE
PEOPLE SO SPECIAL THAT THEY CAN
GET THEIR STUPID COLLEGE, NO!
THAT GUY WITH A TRUCK, HE
DESERVES IT TOO, THEN YOU GET TO
THAT POINT OF OKAY, WHAT OTHER
LOANS CAN YOU CANCEL?
HOW CAN YOU CANCEL THEM?
WHO PAYS FOR IT?
IS THE BANK GOING APPELLATE
LAMENT PAY FOR IT?
HELL NO, IT'S GOING TO BE US.
THAT'S WHY IT WON'T HAPPEN.
>> Juan: I WOULD SAY THAT
EDUCATION HAS A GREAT SOCIAL
VALUE, BUT I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT IN FACT WHEN
CHUCK SCHUMER AND OTHERS SAID
THAT JOE BIDEN SHOULD ISSUE AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER, HE DID NOT.
HE REFUSED THAT.
SO WHAT WE HAVE NOW IS THAT THIS
IS NOT IN A PRESIDENTIAL BUDGET
PROPOSAL, BUT REMEMBER THE POWER
OF THE PURSES WITH THE CONGRESS.
SO IF CONGRESS WANTS TO PASS
LEGISLATION THAT CONTAINS THIS
$10,000 LOAN FORGIVENESS, THEN
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BASICALLY
SAID HE IS WILLING TO SIGN IT IF
IT IS A LEGISLATION THAT COMES
FROM THE CONGRESS.
SO CONGRESS HAS THAT RIGHT, BUT
I THINK THE LARGER POINT IS THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS OTHER PRIORITIES
WHICH IS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
DEAL, THE CHILD TAX CREDIT, THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT FOR THE
WORKING PEOPLE I THINK THAT HE
SAYS THAT'S HIS PRIORITY NOT THE
STUDENT DEBT FORGIVENESS.
>> Katie: JESSE.
>> Jesse: I DON'T WANT TO PLAY
INTO THE BIDEN VERSUS THE SQUAD
THING.
IT JUST MAKES JOE LOOK MODERATE.
AS CRAZY VERSUS CRAZY, THERE ARE
BOTH CRAZY.
JUST BECAUSE JOE IS LESS CRAZY
DOESN'T MAKE HIM SANE.
THEY ARE USING EACH OTHER, THE
SQUAD SAYING OH COMING OUT, WE
ARE PROGRESSIVE PUSHING THIS OLD
RELIC TO THE FAR LEFT, LOOK HOW
POWERFUL WE ARE.
AND JOE BIDEN IS SAYING I'M NOT
A SOCIALIST, I BEAT THE
SOCIALIST.
I'M SO POWERFUL AND MODERATE.
THEY ARE ON THE SAME TEAM IT'S A
LOVE FEST, THEY CONTROL
WASHINGTON AND THEY CAN DO
WHATEVER CRAZY THING THEY WANT
FOR TWO YEARS UNTIL THE COUNTRY
HE THROWS THEM OUT.
SO THE SQUAD IS SAYING, LET'S GO
CRAZY FOR TWO YEARS AND JOE IS
SAYING, LET'S SEE HOW MUCH CRAZY
WE CAN GET AWAY WITH IN TWO
YEARS.
BUT THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT
DEMOCRATS, THEY CREATED
THEMSELVES.
THEY DON'T FIX PROBLEMS, THEY
JUST CREATE PROBLEMS AND SLAP A
CRISIS LABEL ON IT LIKE IT CAME
OUT OF NOWHERE AND THEN THROW
OUR TAX DOLLARS AT IT AND WANT
CREDIT FOR BEING COMPASSIONATE.
NO.
>> Greg: I LIKE THIS "I DON'T
CARE ANYMORE JESSE WATTERS